[Musica]
[Applauso]
nel 2016 ho fatto la mia prima visita
psichiatrica
da molto tempo
la mia mente andava una sola di due
velocità o a mille o a zero
alla velocità massima avevo scritto un
libro avevo pubblicato illustrazioni
avevo una carriera avevo costruito una
casa famiglia per cani anziani e
disabili ne avevo fatti adottare più di
cantavo disegnavo dipingevo ma
ciclicamente mi pervadeva una malinconia
esistenziale
una grande sofferenza un mal di vivere e
faticavo a rimanere funzionale
nonostante la psicoterapia la vita mi
era diventata faticosamente
insopportabile
uscì da quella visita con una diagnosi
di disturbo dell'umore
è un sacchetto di farmaci
farmaci che sono stati aggiustati
nell'arco di due anni Mentre la mia vita
andava avanti
nel 2018 la violenta separazione da
quello che allora era il mio compagno e
convivente fece precipitare il mio stato
mentale la seconda psichiatra della mia
vita
andiamo in Toy farmaci
antipsicotici antidepressivi
stabilizzatori dell'umore
all'ultima visita a cui Andai
accompagnata perché non riuscivo a
tenere gli occhi aperti la persona che
avrebbe dovuto curarmi si è premurata di
dire all'amica che era con me
che non lo vedi che matta
Guarda come porta i capelli
sicuramente se l'è tagliati da sola
io mi taglio i capelli
e non Saloon extra lusso da 15 anni
perché matta sì ma le doppie punte non
mi avranno mai
mi rivolsi al pronto soccorso una prima
volta
perché non dormivo più di un'ora
consecutiva da due settimane mi fecero
del Tavor e mi mandarono a casa
la seconda volta mia madre mi chiamo
l'ambulanza perché avevo le
allucinazioni
scambiai i paramedici per i pompieri e
mi si urlare perché pensavo che mi stai
andando a fuoco casa
mi fecero del Tavor e se ne andarono
la terza volta
Ormai in preda un delirio psicotico mi
Portarono in psichiatria
avevo appena compiuto 38 anni
in psichiatria
si scende
in un sotterraneo come all'inferno
in quel luogo quasi senza finestre
legata mani e piedi a letto oppure se
data Io ci sono stata un mese
Nessuno mi ha fatto una doccia
i denti me li lavavano le mie amiche
il personale si rifiutava morde dicevano
da allora di denti ne ho persi quattro
con grande gioia del mio dentista
impazzire
è la paura più grande dell'essere umano
nascondiamo I matti dove non possiamo
vederli
Dove possiamo tenere celato la nostra
paura di perdere il senno E poi nel
romanticizziamo l'esistenza
come con Van Gogh o Alda Merini
Ma io non ero Alda Merini
a nessuno è venuto un dubbio nessuno si
è fatto una domanda
per un mese sono stata lì
sveglia è legata oppure se data con una
quantità di farmaci che avrebbero
stroncato un cavallo
poi
un giorno è successo qualcosa
a qualcuno è venuto un dubbio
in medicina si dice
quando senti rumore di zoccoli
pensi ai cavalli
Ma io
era una zebra
mi ha salvata un neurologo che di zebre
come me ne aveva viste già due
così
in carrozzina col pannolone il catetere
la nutrizione parenterale le crisi
epilettiche
camminavo più non parlavo più non
deglutivo più
la zebra una malattia psichiatrica non
ce l'aveva mai avuta
in realtà
avevo un tumore
un tumore dell'ovaio
che di solito è benigno Ma quando uno è
fortunata come me
scatena una potentissima e rarissima
reazione autoimmune con il nome
difficile
che si chiama
encefalite limpica autoimmune
antirecettori nmda
Il mio cervello era in fiamme
così
mi hanno tolto una Tuba un ovaio
e la portate in neurologia dove il
sistema sanitario nazionale mi ha
consentito di curarmi con un anticorpo
monoclonale da migliaia di euro
me lo ricordo Ogni volta che faccio la
dichiarazione dei redditi
poi dopo un altro mese sono uscita
camminavo male
parlavo pochissimo capivo ancora meno
E soprattutto non mi ricordavo niente
Ho passato settimane a chiedere ai miei
genitori ma io
sono sposata
Ma che lavoro faccio
Ma dove sono stata tutto questo tempo ho
dei figli
quando mi hanno portato dal parrucchiere
la prima volta mi sono persa tra il
sedile del lavaggio è quello del taglio
non ho riconosciuto
l'estetista che mi faceva le mani da 10
anni
e quando mi ha chiesto
che colore le vuoi
Io mi sono girata verso mia madre
e l'ho detto mamma
che colore mi piace
Ti piace il rosso
mi ha detto
così risposi
Fammele rosse
l'ironia della vita è incredibile sapete
che lavoro facevo
16 anni mi sono occupata di
riabilitazione delle funzioni cognitive
dei bambini con danni cerebrali
e quando la mia mente si affollava di
pensieri e mi sembrava di impazzire
dicevo ridendo alle amiche
se avessi mezzo cervello stare meglio
Bisogna stare molto molto attenti a
quello che si desidera
l'universo
ce lo potrebbe fare avere
il primo anno fu terribile
ogni giorno pensavo a come togliermi la
vita
dove tira imparare a vestirmi a lavarmi
a cucinare un piatto di pasta accendere
la lavatrice
e poi a guidare a interagire con le
persone a capire gli stati mentali
dell'altro
ai test avevo perso 30 punti di cui
Ma siccome partivo da una Plus dotazione
Il range era normale
nessuno aveva idea di cosa fare per me
non solo tutto era difficilissimo
ma era come se la malattia mi avesse
tolto la parte del cervello che mi
serviva per fare le cose belle
esprimermi con la creatività che mi
aveva sempre contraddistinta era
impossibile
niente di quello che mi emozionava mi
dava più un briciolo di gioia ero viva
ma senza vita
alcuni rapporti mi ricordavano
costantemente la persona che ero e
vedevo
in visibilizzata non vista la persona
che ero diventata
era molto doloroso
il secondo anno con una lentezza
esasperante
andò meglio
ma all'inizio del terzo era chiaro che
ormai ero rimasta bloccata in una vita
che non era più la mia
come quel vestito che non ti entra più e
che ti fa rimpiangere il corpo che avevi
mi sentivo sepolta viva
sono nata due volte
la mia seconda vita è iniziata
quando Come un serpente
ho lasciato andare la vecchia pelle
ormai scomoda stretta
quando ha Reciso i rami secchi che
impedivano alla persona che ero
diventata di fiorire
porti che non mi nutrivano più
un lavoro che all'inizio era troppo
difficile Troppo complesso e poi troppo
doloroso perché riapriva ferite che
risuonavano come campane a lutto
piaceri che non erano più piaceri
e così
nel pozzo di disperazione
in cui ero finita
ho trovato una gemma preziosissima
un minuscolo impulso di spinta Vitale
dovevo fare qualcosa che non avevo mai
fatto perché quello che avevo sempre
fatto non funzionava più
e così mi sono aperta un profilo su
Instagram
per parlare di una cosa dico una mamma
avevo mai parlato ne ho parlato di tante
cose
volevo parlare di sessualità non
convenzionale
poi mi sono chiesta Chissà se può
diventare un lavoro e così mi sono
iscritta al master in sessuologia
Nel frattempo sono diventata
l'assistente di una sessuologa che con
grande generosità mi ha insegnato a
lavorare
finito il master dopo un anno avevo
10.000 persone che mi seguivano
abbastanza per una nuova carriera
ho cominciato
un percorso con uno psicoterapeuta
specializzato in cambi di carriera e
persone ad alto potenziale
alla fine del percorso siamo diventati
amici e la mia carriera è decollata
se vuoi avere qualcosa che ti faccia
stare bene
devi fare spazio
E togliere quello che ti fa stare male
accettare la persona che non sei più
fare i conti con i tuoi vuoti le tue
mancanze
gli errori che hai fatto
rimanere agganciati a qualcosa che non
ti rappresenta più
è come fare la veglia al morto
e accanimento terapeutico a nutrire
qualcosa che non è più vitale
chiudila quella relazione stantio
cambialo quel lavoro che non ti piace
allontana quelle relazioni a cui ormai
ti lega solo l'affetto del tempo
trascorso
buttalo quel vestito che non ti entra e
un'ora il corpo che hai oggi forse il
tuo corpo come il mio è cambiato
il corpo non è fatto per essere guardato
il corpo è fatto per sentire per
esperire
per entrare in contatto per emozionarci
è la tua casa è la casa che abiti
ringrazialo
attraversare il mio personale inferno mi
ha insegnato
stare col dolore a non averne paura a
non rifuggirlo a non temerlo
a sedermi vicino a lui a conoscerlo
abbracciarlo
e scoprire che questo è l'unico modo per
farlo scivolare via
ho scoperto
che se ti agiti in modo scomposto i
legacci stringono più forte
ho scoperto
tutti i libri e manuali
sulle separazioni sul lutto sulle
perdite
non ti insegnano che cosa fare quando
perdi te stesso
ho scoperto che essere felici
non è qualcosa che accade
è una scelta di campo è una
responsabilità
è una presa di posizione potente
che passa per forza attraverso la
conoscenza profonda di se stessi nella
propria più autentica unicità
ci raccontiamo
che viviamo una vita impossibile perché
il lavoro il matrimonio i figli perché
la vita
ci raccontiamo che non vogliamo ferire
gli altri ma la realtà
è che abbiamo paura
abbiamo paura del conflitto e di non
essere amati per quello che siamo
diventati
scriveva Albert
ho scoperto
infine
che nel bel mezzo dell'inverno vi era in
me una invincibile estate
disprezziamo lo spreco di vita
con gratitudine e fiducia aspettiamo la
nostra primavera
perché quando ci sentiamo sepolti vivi
forse probabilmente
stiamo solo mettendo radici
[Applauso]